[Music]
could you give us a few examples of some
of these commitments
and of course i i would recommend people
read the book i think it's it's very
valuable
but can you give us
a handful of examples of what these
commitments
are yeah the the first
we got a lot of these from gay and katy
hendrix they were the ones they wrote
the first two commitments word for word
and the first two commitments the first
one is all around i commit to take
radical responsibility for the results
in my life
and
that's a cornerstone commitment
and
you know that looks like some guy who i
was coaching the other day called me up
and said my ceo is not giving me the
feedback i need to grow as a leader and
so i had him teach me the class how do
you create the ceo not giving you the
feedback you want he's like what i'm not
creating that he's i'm not the effect of
it he's not giving it to me i said teach
me the class so he
actually thought for a moment and said
well value the ceo's time more than your
time uh don't reschedule when the ceo
breaks your one-on-one meetings
don't ask directly for the feedback you
want
and he started to giggle and realized oh
i'm i'm the creator of not getting the
feedback i want that's radical
responsibility
so
people often we say
the thing you're complaining about is
often the thing you're committed to
creating and if you can own that that's
radical and then the second commitment
is all around letting go of of one team
to be right and what we mean by that is
the defending yourself righteously that
keeps you from learning and growing
those are the two cornerstone
commitments one and two i think we even
say in the book like you could stop
right here and just practice these for
the rest of your life
but then there's the commitment to
really feel feelings and specifically
what i noticed and we talked about this
you and i a little bit when you were
thinking about writing this notebook
was
how much we're trying to control each
other feeling feelings so like i don't
want to say no because i don't want you
to have a feeling over there and i
really think i'm right you shouldn't
have them and i don't want you to have a
feeling because then maybe i'll have a
feeling and i see how much of our drama
in the workplace and at home is coming
from suppressing feelings in ourselves
and each other
candor's a commitment to be able to
say what's going on rather than
conceal it which then causes me to have
to start to withdraw
and
ending gossip
is another commitment
really being impeccable around
agreements so that i do what i say i'm
gonna do it's another commitment those
first six really that's what we focus a
lot in the business world when we come
and work with teams we have them work on
those six commitments
to help secure the identity and relax
drama and then once that's done then we
have things like let's look at
appreciation the commitment to
appreciate
the commitment to play and rest the
commitment to live in our zones of
genius
and then the commitments get even deeper
into
being the source of approval control and
security rather than trying to source it
outside of yourself which is probably
one of the most difficult commitments of
all and also the commitment of
experiencing that you already have
enough
which most people also struggle with
especially at least in the business
world i rarely ever come across anybody
who has enough time
and then and then they go on from there
um to being able to create a win for all
solution which is one of my
just one of my great joys to
work with a team where there's a lot of
different needs and it seems like they
can't come up with a solution where they
all win and helping them do that
and finally be the resolution to that
which you see missing in the world
so if they're not listening be a better
listener
they're not taking care of things take
care of things
you